[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم
مئات المستوطنين يقتحمون باحات المسجد
الاقصى بحمايه كامله من قوات الاحتلال
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه نددت بالخطوه
واعتبرتها امتدادا لمحاولات تغيير الواقع
القانوني والتاريخي القائم في حين طالب
قاده مستوطنات غلاف غزه نتنياهو بتعزيز
حمايه مستوطناتهم بعد اطلاق قضاء صاروخيه
من الاراضي السوريه باتجاه اسرائيل الجيش
الاسرائيلي يقول انه شن غارات على اهداف
تابعه للجيش السوري في محيط العاصمه دمشق
ووزاره الدفاع السوريه تقول ان دفاعاتها
الجويه تصدت لهجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي جنوبي
البلاد لاول مره الجيش الصيني يقول ان
مناوراته في مضيق تايوان تحاكي ضرب اهداف
رئيسيه في الجزيره وضعت قواتها الجويه في
حاله تاهب قصوى ومسؤول امريكي لا يستبعد
ارسال قوات الى تايوان في حين قال الرئيس
الفرنسي ان على اوروبا ان تتجنب الانجرار
مع واشنطن لمواجهه محتمله مع الصين ربع
مليون موعد عمليه جراحيه قد تتاجل في
بريطانيا بسبب اضراب عشرات الاف الاطباء
الشبان السلطات الصحيه عبرت عن قلقها من
ان يكون اضراب الاطباء الاسبوع المقبل
الاكبر من نوعه في القطاع الصحي وسط
مخاوفا من تعرض سلامه المرضى للخطر
[موسيقى]